er macht es tatsächlich ihnen macht baut
die größte batterie waren der welt und
löst damit die stromversorgungs probleme
in südaustralien angefangen hat es mit
einer wette die jetzt gilt in 100 tagen
will macht die batterie farm aus dem
boden stampfen kann das funktionieren
klicks zum ziel kommen
das ist wirklich verrückt ihnen mag
krempelt echt die welt um wo andere
unternehmen wochen monate und jahre
brauchen um zu planen projektieren
angebote einholen und beweise legte
einfach los die industriebosse weltweit
kommen aus dem staunen nicht mehr heraus
und scheinen dem feld mit milliardär und
seinen erfolgen verständnislos zu folgen
das scheint alle herausforderungen wie
ein startup anzugehen selbst die akkus
mit spacex hat er mal im vorbeigehen
einen raumfahrtunternehmen gewonnen es
hat bereits die raumfahrt revolutioniert
und durch die wiederverwendbarkeit der
ersten stufe der felten rakete und der
dragon café die kosten deutlich gesenkt
die raumfahrt ist so in der lage ihm
wirklich neue dimensionen vor zu bringen
seine versprechen scheinen dabei
verrückt aber er kann sie einhalten wenn
wir wirklich absolut faszinierend um es
mal mit spock aus star trek zu sagen
auch bei dem elektroautohersteller tesla
kann was wohl alle seine versprechen
einhalten haben die aktionäre zweifeln
am erfolgskurs aber die produktion des
modells drei startet planmäßig am 9 juli
auf diesem modell baut die zukunft des
autoherstellers der 2016 84.000 teslas
produzierte mit modell 3 wird tesla zum
massenhersteller für den wagen sollen
rund 400.000 bestellungen vorliegen das
wirklich ein bisschen verrückt aus dem
nichts zum führenden elektroauto
hersteller der welt und damit zu einer
wirklich ernstzunehmende konkurrenz für
die alteingesessenen autohersteller mit
dem modell 3 könnte das realität werden
und jetzt die weltgrößte batterie formal
ebenso in 100 tagen wie bitte am 10 märz
hatte marc getwittert dass tesla die
energieprobleme des bundesstaates
südaustralien in 100 tagen lösen könne
südaustralien leidet darunter dass immer
mehr kohlekraftwerke abgeschaltet wurden
und windpark von gaskraftwerke jetzt
nicht in der lage ausreichend strom zu
produzieren
immer wieder kommt es dort zu
stromausfällen ein systembedingt das
problem regenerativer energien egal ob
solarzellen oder windkraftwerke der
strom steht nicht dauerhaft zur
verfügung innenmaß lösung für dieses
problem ein netzwerk aus batterien er
will die energieversorgung
revolutionieren dazu
solar sagt siegl und die power batterien
und batterie formen seine vision ein
netzwerk mit batterien in wohnungen und
häusern und batterie farm und die
stromerzeugung aus der sonne mit tesla
solar ziehen und für die tesla
elektroautos wird so preiswert und
umweltfreundlich strom erzeugt und
erscheint dazu tatsächlich relativ
problemlos in der lage zu sein ein wenig
erinnert das ganze an die einführung des
iphones nur in einem anderen maßstab die
branchengrößen haben damals gelacht
viele von ihnen gibt es heute nicht mehr
mal sehen was so auf dem strom und
automarkt passiert für die batterie farm
in australien geht macht jetzt eine
riesen wetter ein er will sie fahren in
100 tagen bauen dabei wird sie eine
kapazität von 100 megawatt haben wissen
der lage 30.000 häuser gleichzeitig mit
strom zu versorgen und max ist sie damit
dreimal stärker als jede bisher auf der
welt gebaute batterie farm in
kalifornien hatte tesla bereits einer
farm auf batterien anfang 2017
fertiggestellt da man braucht ist häßler
90 tage für 20 megawatt wir können also
sehr gespannt sein was jetzt noch alles
passieren wird für den klimawandel
findet auf jeden fall gute nachrichten
ich hoffe dass es auch so bleibt mehr
über ihren mars gibt es hier mit tempo
200 unterirdisch durch die stadt
da revolutioniert macht den
innerstädtischen verkehr wirklich
ziemlich irre seine pläne einfach
draufklicken und wenn er nichts mehr
über markt neueste pläne verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht dass die glocke dann
verpasst ihr kein video bis dann bleibt
dran